the raiders making waves as they put
together an interesting roster to say
the least richie incognito out of
football for all of 2018 he's had
multiple incidents off the field there
have been times where he engages in
behavior that calls into question deeper
issues that that you know have required
and he's been open about this treatment
and and uh and care for possible mental
health issues and we're very sensitive
to that here and it's something that's
unfairly stigmatized in today's society
but he is embraced by the raiders he is
back he is in the fall now he's still
got to make it onto the 53-man roster
but he's getting a chance and here's
mike mayok the gm of the raiders when he
was asked about richie incognito's
history of us off-field misbehavior
at the end of the day
you can't have all boy scouts and what
you have to do
is you have to do your homework on each
individual case and we've done our
homework we've talked to an awful lot of
people we brought him in we talked to
richie we told richie what we'd expect
both on and off the field
and and we expect him to adhere to that
you know i i get it i mean sometimes you
do your homework and your homework isn't
very good right i don't know what
they're expecting here they're bringing
him in on apparently a one strike
arrangement but you have to ask yourself
does he even deserve that this is chance
number three at a minimum for incognito
he was out of football after the stuff
in miami he went to buffalo things fell
apart there he had the incident off the
field last year ultimately pleaded
guilty to disorderly conduct and no one
wanted him i i just i don't know
you know we say all the time that the
guys who are really talented get the
second chances is incognito good enough
that he even deserves the raiders
sticking their neck out on the line for
him like this yeah okay that's the real
question you're right it's borderline
whether he's worth that you're right
sticking their neck out on the line and
maybe having to deal with some of the
risk that comes along with signing a
richie incognito now uh i'll say this
mike richie incognito is he's a very
good football player i mean yeah he was
one of the better guards in football i'm
not going to say he was a top five guard
in football when he left uh or his last
year at buffalo but he wasn't far away
from being that top five guard in
football all right so this is the first
thing that jumps out to me mike just
like from the pure football standpoint
doesn't make sense to me there richie
incognito is not a zone blocking type of
guard right mike tom cable there the
offensive line coach he is a zone
blocking type of offensive line coach
and that's what they did in seattle when
he was there richie incognito is more of
a man-to-man blocking type guy pulling
guard blocking down traps things like
that so just right off the bat i thought
it was a little weird as far as the
scheme fit two i thought of the things
that you did off the field at a minimum
three strikes at this point right i mean
to what he's had i mean really i think
if we really looked at it we could go ah
there's more than three here and i don't
know if there's anybody really playing
in football right now that has
maybe the the checkered past as richie
incognito is that's where i would
challenge it and that's where it's a
little risky for the raiders
yeah i agree with you completely and you
know what it could just be they want to
have the benefit of his attitude of that
in your face kind of intimidation maybe
just for training camp in the preseason
maybe he doesn't even make the 53-man
roster but having him around toughens up
some of the other linemen mike i think
that's a really valid point and i think
that's what mike mayok's trying to say
is you know you can't have a bunch of
choir boys and you know as you know i
played for john gruden and that is
that's one of his themes you gotta you
gotta have a little edge in the locker
room you have too many nice guys too
many yes this yes that uh and everything
else
yeah usually you don't have a good
football team you look at the really
good football teams there's usually an
edginess about them and there's a few
players that can bring that out within
the locker room and i think that's what
they're looking for for an incognito
they got some young offensive linemen
they're probably trying to show them hey
this is what a real tough sob offensive
lineman acts like on a day-to-day basis
set the attitude for the offensive line
and i would imagine that is certainly
part of the
reason why they signed him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports